kind of a good pop quiz question how old
is the universe people might know it
13.8 billion years why does that number
come from and there's a little bit of a
interesting difference emerging that
might stand the test of time and if it
does stand the test of time it either
means we're not understanding what we're
doing or there's perhaps some new
physics out there that we've not really
accounted for yet and that of course is
the latter would be very exciting
so how do you measure something as vast
as the universe like where do you start
so we think of our universes evolving in
time and there are these special
sections and we're living in part of it
and for large distances they're distant
galaxies will be actually moving apart
if you can figure out you know how far
is that thing and how fast is it moving
away from me and then rewind time then
you can figure out how long the universe
is been expanding for so it essentially
it boils down to sort of speed equals
distance over time really I mean there's
a lot more of complications in there
because we actually know that the
universe is accelerating expanding and
not just expanding it's getting faster
all the time and then also the sort of
effects of general activity when you
bring in really really distant objects
but basically is speed equals distance
over time we can either measure it by
looking at galaxies that are not that
far away from us and determining how
they're evolving with respect to one
another and we these we do these music
well I said when I say not that far away
from those I have to be a little bit
careful some of these galaxies were
looking at about seven billion years old
so they are a hell of a long way away
from us so to measure this you obviously
you can't just use one object you need a
lot of them he justit just takes to be
good so let's start with distance okay
so how do you measure the distance of an
object again it uses a concept that
people might be quite familiar with so
use this idea of apparent brightness so
if you're crossing the street at night
left right Green Cross code all that but
you'll see a car headlights coming
towards you and you'll know whether it's
safe to cross because
you know how bright color headlights
normally are when they're right near you
and you'll say okay well it's not that
bright and so I can figure out that it's
far enough away that it's safe for me to
cross so our numbers basically use the
same concept and they say okay we need
to find something that we know what
brightness it should be and how bright
it appears can tell us how far away it
is by looking for what we might call
standard candles in them and these are
the supernovae and they're typical ones
type 1a supernovae in type 1a you have a
binary star system one of them will have
reached the end of its life and have got
normal supernova okay and what it will
of left behind is its core which we call
the white dwarf I'll probably still be
glowing somewhat well that white dwarf
is sort of held up by is this thing
called electron degeneracy pressure that
the whole thing is held up by the fact
that the electrons don't want to pushed
any closer together the other star
though meanwhile is sort of still
orbiting around it okay still in it's
sort of normal life cycle but eventually
it will start to run out of hydrogen and
it will swell to what we call the red
giant and then that's probably going to
come in to sort of the sphere of
influence of this little white dwarf and
that white dwarf is gonna start sort of
accreting that material from that other
star and then it's gonna keep building
up mass and building up its mass until
it reaches the point where those
electrons being pushed together can't
support it anymore
and then it will go supernova in this
type warning okay again yeah supernova
twice Wow pretty cool the thing is
because of that electron degeneracy
pressure because electrons are the same
across the entire universe that mass
that it reaches one point four times the
mass of the Sun is the same everywhere
therefore it's always going to explode
with the same energy so from that you
can calculate the distance quite easily
knowing that their brightness is doing
so much over that distance yeah good
question so you know all the type one is
have a very dislike distinctive
signature in their spectra so not just
that all of the light we receive if we
take that light and split it through a
prism and we look at its constituent
parts it'll have a very specific
signature in its elements so first of
all you have to be able to recognize
what type it is and then you can say
okay so how bright does that appear now
so it's all about because these things
happen really quickly and start to fade
really quickly you have to have sort of
like really quick response times for
telescopes to be able to figure out what
these things are so you see a type 1a go
off in a galaxy you know how bright it
should be you know how bright it looked
and that tells you how far away that
whole galaxy is exactly yeah it's really
difficult to tell the distance to
galaxies themselves because you have no
idea what size the galaxy could be you
know it could be the same size as the
Milky Way it might not be it might be
bigger it might be smaller and so when
you have a supernova that's then bright
enough to outshine that entire galaxy
you can then put a distance on that so
now we need the speed okay so we need to
know the speed that this galaxy that the
supernova is residing in is moving away
from us again we use a handy little
phenomenon called redshift okay so
people might have heard of this before
it's this idea that because the universe
is expanding the light that's given off
by that supernova will be stretched as
it travels across that space okay and it
will be shifted and lengthened to longer
wavelengths or to redder wavelengths
since redshift because it is being
stretched we can then say okay we can
convert that into a speed at which that
is moving away from us similar to a
Doppler shift so we can turn
shift of say 0.5 into a recession
velocity and again you're gonna need the
spectra of that supernova not just to
identify that it is a type 1a but
actually look at the light see how much
it's been shifted by and therefore
calculate the speed that it's moving
away from us so basically what we gonna
end up with I'm gonna draw this is very
exciting and you can end up with a nice
plot of your distance gonna be in a
really weird unit that astronomers like
called a mega parsec which is a distance
not a time thanks star wars and then
you're gonna have it against basically
redshift which will be in be translated
into a speed in kilometers per second
and what you end up with you're gonna
measure this for as many supernova as
you can and you can end up with them all
sort of dotted like this give me up to
draw a nice best-fit line through them
okay because what you'll see is that
your velocity that your receding out is
gonna be proportional to your distance
there's a nice correlation there so
actually what we end up calling this
proportional constant is the Hubble's
constant or H naught here like that and
this H naught is going to basically be
in kilometers per second per megaparsec
okay so you'll notice this is a distance
and this is the measure of distance so
really if we put those in the same units
and we cancel them out it'd really be in
1 over seconds
and so if we do 1 over H naught I'm
gonna end up with something that's in
seconds which will give us the age of
the universe at a time there is a lot of
uncertainty in this method how do you
know also that you're getting the right
value what you ideally need is another
method to be able to confirm whether
that value you're getting is right or
not with supernovae the current
supernovae camp is saying that the
Hubble's constant is seventy three point
two four kilometers per second per
megaparsec and then there's another way
there are there a number of ways but the
second way which I think is particularly
interesting is by looking at the very
early universe
I'm looking at the fluctuations in the
temperature of the universe due to
events that occurred at the very
beginning of the universe maybe due to
inflation repetitive motions and and you
can look at the hot and cold spots and
and look at the the radiation that's
emitted in the turn and it reaches us in
the microwave background microwave range
so it's called the cosmic microwave
background radiation now you can fit the
hot and cold spots the distribution of
these temperature fluctuations with a
given cosmological model you pick your
cosmological model and you see how well
it fits the debt and the best fitting
cosmological model is called the
lambda-cdm model lambda as in the
cosmological constant it gives you a
value of H not today which is about 66
kilometers per second per megaparsec so
you think oh come on they're close
enough one's measuring the universe as a
result of physics that we're seeing that
have occurred three hundred thousand
years 380,000 years after the Big Bang
one is you know much more recent 7
billion years or so after the Big Bang
and you within no percent the issue is
this that the each of the sets of people
that have been doing these measurements
of working very hard to understand the
uncertainties in their measurement and
the uncertainties both in their
experiments their systemic concern T's
and they've both now reached a stage
where they error bars over each don't
overlap with one another anymore so
there's been a lot of contention for a
very long time about what value is
actually right for Hubble's constant and
ideally what you want is a completely
independent measure we didn't have that
for a very long time until 2017 so in
2017 there was a neutron star a neutron
star collision detected by the LIGO and
Vega collaboration and the really cool
thing about it was that there was also
an optical detection of the same event
ok so not only did you check the
gravitational waves we detected it in
optical and gamma and x-ray and all of
these different electromagnetic spectrum
radiation which is really exciting but
it also meant that it became what's
known as a standard siren so notice that
a candle or a standard ruler but
standard siren so something that you
know how Lau
it should be and then you can compare it
to how loud you observe it to be so from
the gravitational waves we got how loud
is it supposed to be compared to what I
model it to be and then from the light
that we detected we again got a redshift
and therefore we could know its distance
so but you're dying to know what value
they found yeah yeah and if they solved
the whole mystery yeah okay so here's
the paper gravitational wave standard
siren measurement of the Hubble constant
and this is what people had been waiting
for in cosmology for years and I guess
you want to see the plot this blue line
is what they got from the baryon
acoustic oscillations with the standards
rulers this is what you got from
standard candles of supernovae and then
this line here is the likelihood of the
Hubble constant being that value given
this stock this one neutron star
collision can you see right where it
falls right in the middle at about 70
kilometers per second per megaparsec
yeah I know it's so annoying because
though people were waiting for so long
as soon as people heard that this
happened they were like constant we're
finally gonna know and it was just right
down the middle of so far as one
measurements of course and so I'm sure I
assume they think there's some big error
bars on it for it to become a
significant player then you've got to
have lots and lots of neutron star
mergers from which you can then build up
the statistics from what I recall for
the next few years they're not expecting
to see very many we've order one a few a
year well that means you're going to be
waiting 10 20 30 years to build up
significant statistics on it we're
basically in a waiting game now to see
what happens with this and whether we
can actually be sure of what the
Hubble's constant is or not the equation
to work out when the time when it began
is trivial it's a really terrific Utley
quotient it only consists of two terms
in it and one it but one of them is the
evolution of the Hubble parameter H
naught is its value today but it evolved
in time and the way it evolved in time
depended on what's in the universe and
that's the thing people are trying to
pin down you know how much of it is
matter how much you is called out matter
how much it is dark energy how much is
in the curvature
the space-time and different
combinations of those three will give me
a different edge to the universe try to
calculate it yeah okay yeah let's do it
t what's your time of your universe is
going to be 1 over your measurement for
the Hubble's constant and so the Hubble
constant that the LIGO team found was 70
plus 12 minus 8 because it wasn't very
precise kilometers per second per
megaparsec we're gonna have 1 over 70
basically so one mega parsec is three
point zero eight six times 10 to the 22
meters that value is burnt on your brain
if you've done and I strongly degree ok
so what we're actually gonna do is we're
gonna do 1 divided by 70,000 put through
made it into meters okay so that's
meters per second and then divide that
by three point zero eight six times 10
to the 22 meters okay and then you'll be
thankful to him that I did that
calculation before and it was four point
four one times 10 to the 17 seconds so
let's turn that into years okay so if we
divide it by 60 we get it in minutes if
we divide that by 60 again we get it in
hours we do that by 24 we get it in days
and we divide that by 365 point two five
we get it in years and you don't know
what that comes out as mm-hmm thirteen
point nine seven billion yes so that
means if I mean that's so exact that
means if we like to use a calendar and
go back we can find out if the Big Bang
happened on a Wednesday yeah you really
want to do that would be really cool
actually we should do that thirteen
point nine seven billion obviously you
can't quote it to that accuracy because
Lycos estimate was seventy plus 12 minus
8 so really we could only say fourteen
billion years but it's pretty close to
sort of the thirteen point eight that
people always quote that obviously is
from one of those two camps but it
obviously varies so people take a nice
average
okay so at Brady's request okay
considering the fact that the detection
was made on the 17th of August 2017 and
using the numbers published in the paper
and using these numbers here we have
calculated that the Big Bang happened on
a Tuesday it's either a Monday or a
Tuesday and March 6 minus 6 is my
birthday I mean it's pretty clear that
that's when it was yeah if you enjoyed
this video can I also recommend our
astronomy channel deep sky videos which
features a lot of the same people you
see on sixty symbols in addition to some
really cool videos about telescopes the
main thing we're doing is making a
hundred and ten films about the so
called Messier objects this is a list of
a hundred and ten things in space that
were listed by an astronomer called
Charles Messier he was interested in
comets and these hundred and ten objects
he knew weren't comets they were smudgy
on the sky like a comet but they never
moved so it was kind of like an anti
list avoid these things it was only many
years later when telescopes got better
we realized Messier list wasn't boring
stuff you should avoid but was in fact
an incredible bunch of things including
galaxies clusters of stars nebulae
things Messier probably hadn't even
thought of
now we've done more than half of the 110
I think we must have done about 60 we're
not doing them in order we're sort of
jumping all over the place
but if you'd like to watch them I'll put
a link on the screen and in the video
description
that's deep sky videos but in the
meantime thanks for watching sixty
symbols and we'll see you here again
saying